new questions tonight over fired FBI
director james comey 'he's friendship
with a columbia law professor after Fox
News learns that that professor also had
security clearance chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge reports
on whether a line may have been crossed
in an email to Fox News columbia law
professor daniel richmond confirmed he
worked for then FBI director james comey
as a special government employee known
by the shorthand s GE on an unpaid basis
sources familiar with Richmond's FBI
work said Comey assigned him to special
projects he had a security clearance as
well as badge access to the building
Republican lawmakers want more answers
maybe we need to talk to mr. Richmond
under oath in front of members of the
judiciary in the Oversight Committee
it'd have been nice if we'd have had a
full understanding of the full
relationship that mr. Comey had with the
guy who orchestrated the leak
during his June 2017 testimony Comey did
not describe Richmond as an FBI employee
the former director testified that he
gave the memos documenting conversations
with the president to Richmond to
kick-start what is now the mother probe
I asked a friend of mine to share the
content of the memo with a reporter
didn't do it myself for a variety of
reasons but I asked him to because I
thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel who was
that a good friend of mine who's a
professor at Columbia Law School another
special government employee who has come
under scrutiny was Hillary Clinton aide
Huma Abedin Judiciary Committee Chairman
Senator Chuck Grassley among others
previously questioned Abidine special
status
the latter to work at the Clinton State
Department in private sector at the same
time while the FBI declined to answer
specific questions about Richmond's role
Fox News understands Richmond was sent
talking points on the Clinton email
investigation comparing and contrasting
Clinton's use of an unsecured personal
server for government business with the
case of retired General David Petraeus
and sandy Berger the late national
security adviser under President Clinton
three sources tell Fox News that some or
all of the Comey memos were shared with
at least one other person beyond
professor Richmond and former US
Attorney Patrick Fitzgerald was
identified as the likely recipient mr.
Fitzgerald who is a former Special
Counsel and now one of Comus personal
attorneys did not
respond to multiple requests from Fox
for comment Brett Catherine thank you